all right everybody I hate that I have
to do this video but after more than two
weeks I don't have a choice anymore
because our YouTube channel is quite
frankly on the verge of death uh you
know I know that haters joke about David
you're you're circling the drain and all
of this stuff quite frankly as far as
the YouTube channel is concerned
things look absolutely terrible right
now I was hoping that this would resolve
and that I wouldn't even come to you
with this as a big strong guy right uh
but it's getting worse something has
happened and our videos are no longer
being recommended to viewers in the way
that for years and years they were now
you will notice there are no conspiracy
theories here or irresponsible
speculation it's me telling you the
facts and the numbers and then giving
the most charitable hypothesis about
what happened we have 1.6 million
subscribers on YouTube
and there are now videos that are
sometimes getting 2 000 views now I know
my haters will say David that's because
your videos suck well some of them may
suck okay I won't I won't deny that but
as a sheer mathematical reality with 1.6
million subscribers
our videos would never get 2 000 views
even a bad video was fifteen thousand
twenty thousand views here's the story
on January 9th mysteriously there was a
roughly six to seven hour period during
which our live analytics showed almost
no views like not few views but just
almost zero and we're putting that up on
the screen as little as like 1900 views
in an entire hour during a time of day
where we'd normally have a hundred
thousand views in an hour or even more
this impacted our Channel and others our
channel was not the only one impacted by
this some of uh our colleagues in
left-wing politics were impacted by this
and people outside of politics were
impacted by this fine YouTube told us
your views are fine this is just a
reporting glitch so this is sort of like
you know if a smoke detector goes off
it might go off because there's smoke
but it might go off because the smoke
detector is broken malfunctioning we
were told the views are fine fine
the next day things were supposedly
fixed after three or four days some
slightly higher numbers were replaced in
our analytics for that six seven hour
period on January 9th but I could
immediately tell that views were dead
subscribers were flat one day we even
lost subscribers after gaining
subscribers every day for years we
actually lost three subscribers net one
day and since January 9th the channel
has been dead
there are videos that after 90 minutes
after two hours have 2 000 or fewer
views we're putting that up on the
screen for you to take a look at again
this is something that just hasn't
happened in years and you do the math
with 1.6 million subscribers it just
doesn't pass the sniff test views
Revenue are down 60 or 70 percent
subscribers are at a crawl now this is
happening to many channels of people
that you know I'm not going to mention
them it's not appropriate if they choose
to talk about what's going on that's
absolutely fine for them to do however
it is not affecting all of our channels
there are some creators in news and
politics whose channels are doing
absolutely fine now I genuinely have no
idea what is happening but I have some
speculations okay
I am not claiming at this time that
anybody at YouTube did anything
malicious I am not claiming at this time
that YouTube made a decision let's screw
over David Pacman and a bunch of these
other creators I don't have the evidence
to say that so that is not my hypothesis
at this point in time so something took
us completely out of the recommendation
algorithm I even notice it when browsing
YouTube on my personal account uh not
connected to the David Pacman show
channel I used to get my own videos
recommended they are completely gone
here is one of dozens and dozens of
emails from viewers explaining this Tom
Rhoden and said
I exclusively scroll through the
recently uploaded YouTube category but
other categories are likely populated by
similar algorithmic logic I noticed a
month or two ago I stopped seeing your
videos recommended I had to manually
search for your channel to find it this
also happened with some of my other
favorite creators all of those in your
channel have one thing in common I
started to ignore those videos on
YouTube because I watched them on other
platforms patreon Etc since then I've
noticed that whatever Channel I click on
in recently uploaded has a massive
impact on what is recommended in the
future dozens of emails like that I am
going to give you the most innocent
explanation okay the most innocent
explanation is there was this glitch on
January 9th and it heard us during that
six hour period but it then caused
something to happen
which led to no engagement maybe it was
a period during which our videos didn't
come up as recommended for people
anymore whatever it was it became a
vicious cycle and it told YouTube no
one's clicking David's videos so stop
recommending them all together
that's not me saying someone did it
I don't know but it is what happened so
right now we have to see if we can fix
this I need you to help me with super
simple tasks that cost nothing okay we
need to try to re-engineer our way into
the algorithm if this doesn't work it
will be a really good piece of data
about what might be going on now if it
works that's absolutely fantastic so
here's what I would ask you to do I
believe if a few thousand people do this
it may fix the problem first do a search
for David Pacman on YouTube and click on
one of our videos do it a second time do
it a third time the key is search for
David pakman click on the videos which
will train the algorithm this is what
people are looking for when you click
onto my videos
please make sure you are subscribed
please please please and make sure after
subscribing that you click the Bell
and select all this tells YouTube Not
only am I subscribed I want to see
David's videos in my feed
please like the video and if you can
please leave a comment now ideally if
YouTube then shows you more of my videos
and the recommendations either to the
side or below the video you're watching
click another one of my videos ideally
like it comment the idea is string back
to back videos of mine together which is
hopefully training the YouTube algorithm
this is the this is the path people are
actually looking for now if you don't
get any recommendations for my videos if
you only get Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy
Kimmel and other people named Jimmy
search for me again click like comment
now
if this entire thing is nothing
nefarious and we simply fell out of the
algorithm just several hundred or
ideally a couple of thousand of you out
of the 1.6 million subscribers and some
non-subscribers doing this
this might fix the problem completely
and resolve it if it doesn't then it'll
be really useful information and
whatever's going on is even worse than
we thought now the other part YouTube
revenue is down 60 to 70 percent
we count on that we're counting on using
that money to launch the Spanish Channel
we are very close to launching a dubbed
to Spanish version of our channel to hit
the Spanish-speaking Community dubbing
is really really expensive really really
expensive thousands of dollars per month
we were counting on the revenue from the
main channel to fund the dubbing on the
Spanish channel so this is a very bad
time for this to be happening please
grab a membership at joinpakman.com okay
it's really cheap you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now you'll get a sizable
discount pay full price or not whatever
we just need to supplement 60 to 70
percent is a big big big big deal so
let's do it let's give this 48 hours and
then I will report back to you whether
this did anything at all anything at all
to deal with this algorithmic issue that
we are experiencing and if it doesn't
then it will give us more information
and we can go from there